several g7 leaders are summit hopping
today heading from
england to brussels where nato is
holding a meeting of its
30 heads of state and government u.s
president joe biden wants to
strengthen america's ties with the
alliance after the trump administration
for the first time nato leaders are
expected to adopt a statement pledging
more action against global warming
nato's troop withdrawal from afghanistan
is also on the agenda
members are expected to call on china to
respect
international commitments ahead of the
opening secretary general yen
stoltenberg
clarified its position on beijing
there are of course opportunities and we
need to engage with
china on issues like climate change
arms control but china's
military buildup growing
influence and coercive behavior
also poses some challenges to our
security and we need to address them
together
as an alliance we're not entering a new
cold war and
china is now not our adversary not our
enemy
but we need to address together
as the alliance uh the challenges that
the rights of china poses
to our security tw correspondent terry
schultz is standing by at nato
headquarters
so terry nato secretary general there
saying that uh
we're not entering a new cold war with
china but what
can we expect from nato in its response
to china
good morning terry yes nato very much
hopes there will not be
a new cold war with china uh china
spends with
abandon on its military it has the
second largest
armed forces in the world after the
united states and it already has the
largest
navy it is not bound by any arms control
treaties
so this is very much a country that nato
wants to keep
on the level it does not want increased
tensions especially when the
relationship with russia is going so
badly and requires
so much attention from nato allies so i
would say that secretary general
stoltenberg was being
a bit euphemistic in saying that it is
not an adversary
that's how nato wants to keep it but
nato allies are very worried
the united states foremost among them
okay so
what else is on the agenda there today
at that nato cemetery
well even though china has risen to the
top of the agenda which i might add is
quite interesting because it was only
2019
the first time nato addressed china at
all
but everything else still remains on the
agenda as i mentioned russia very much a
concern
relations with russia going very badly
especially between the u.s and russia
which hopefully will be addressed later
this week when presidents biden and
putin meet bilaterally in geneva
the the trump administration's
insistence on european allies spending
more on their own militaries trying to
get to this two percent pledge
that's not going away either and
president biden is going to be quite
stringent about this
perhaps putting it in more delicate ways
but the united states
is really tired of european allies not
putting enough
money and resources into their own armed
forces
one other issue that is that is quite
interesting rising up nato's agenda as
what they call a crisis multiplier
it will be high on today's summit uh
communique
that is climate change
there's a new air of opportunity for
nato to expand its vision
now that improved transatlantic ties
have eased concerns over the alliance's
most
fundamental mission collective defense
we consider
article 5 a sacred commitment this gives
nato secretary general yen stoltenberg
space to launch initiatives unthinkable
during the trump administration
among his highest ambitions for nato to
become
a leader in combating global warming for
its own sake as militaries are having to
adapt their operations and installations
to rising temperatures
as well as prepare to respond to more
natural disasters and crises over taxed
resources
what we have to do is partly to
improve the way we just understand the
link between security
and and climate change we need to adapt
the way we
conduct our missions and operations and
then we have to reduce
emissions from military operations
stoltenberg
would like to see nato militaries
contribute more to the goal of carbon
neutrality by the year 2050
but there won't be any binding
commitments some governments are less
than enthusiastic about climate action
becoming a nato issue but stoltenberg
is undeterred even if you're not very
concerned about global warming you
should be concerned about the
need to have modern military equipment
and i'm absolutely certain that in the
future modern military equipment
will be environmentally friendly one
immediate task will be to help countries
figure out how much their defense
sectors
actually emit because today few
countries measure
those that do are allowed to keep the
figure secret
when you look at the tables here you
know it's non-reported and unreported et
cetera
european union lawmaker marlon bjork
helped lead an effort to expose military
emissions of some european countries
even though climate agreements do not
require governments to account for them
it is unacceptable that the military is
exempt from reporting obligations
and then also from strategies to reduce
carbon emissions
a 2019 report by brown university
identified the u.s
military as the largest single emitter
of greenhouse gases on the planet but
european militaries are also responsible
and must do their share says former head
of the dutch defense forces tom
middendorp
he was nicknamed the green general
several years ago
when he started pressing this message
i'm not a climate activist i'm really
i'm a military professional
now retired middendorp devotes much of
his time to what he calls
climate-proofing defense he insists this
is not
optional now we are finding out how it
shapes our security environment how it
shapes our geopolitical environment and
how it affects our capabilities
so increasingly we realize that we have
to take this seriously and that we need
to be part of that game to counter it
and even if allies are divided
middendorp encourages stoltenberg
to aim high and fight hard for climate
action
so terry big issues being discussed
there at that nato summit including the
implications of climate change but nuts
and bolts
problems still need addressing not least
afghanistan
nato is pulling its troops out there the
drawdown is due to be complete later
this year
is that all really settled now
it sort of feels that way terry because
of course afghanistan used to be so
high on the agenda of every nato meeting
and
it's not going to be at this summit
we've talked about some of the things
that are of really pressing concern
china climate change
cyber uh is also going to be something
that that has talked about
the challenges from russia af with
afghanistan with the drawdown decided
with
with nato and u.s forces pulling out by
september at the latest as it's now
planned it sort of feels like that big
decision
has been made nato does have a lot of
questions to answer about its future
relationship with afghanistan because it
has pledged to continue supporting the
afghan armed forces
it also says that it will continue to
help protect women to keep girls in
school
to help protect civil society that that
has been allowed to grow
while they while the armed forces have
been there while the nato
forces have been there and those people
and those institutions are very
concerned now
without the protection of international
forces and nato
doesn't have the answers to these
questions yet secretary general
stoltenberg
is honest about that they're going to
have to talk about how they continue to
support this country
where they devoted the last two decades
to trying to stabilize it
terry thank you so much as always that
was dw correspondent terry schultz in
brussels
now g7 leaders wrapped up their summit
over the weekend addressing some of the
world's biggest challenges including the
pandemic and
climate change but more than anything
the summit in cornwall england was a
chance to
reassert transatlantic unity after the
fractious
trump years coveted 19
climate change and china challenges that
both united
and divided leaders of the world's
largest economies
as they closed out their three-day
summit devoted to a shared pledge
to build back better brushing aside a
squabble over brexit in northern ireland
british prime minister boris johnson
proclaimed it a hugely successful
meeting of minds there has been a
fantastic
degree of harmony i mean between
the leaders of the uh of our of our
countries and and if you look at some of
things
they come together uh to uh to agree in
a billion
uh more doses a billion more uh vaccines
everyone agreed to phase out
uh the use of coal a new atlantic
charter
uh a plan to build back better for the
world i don't think that
uh really i could have asked for a more
cooperative or
a more energetic spirit from uh from our
friends
and friendships were a dominant theme
with u.s president joe biden and his
committed transatlanticism warmly
embraced
biden declared victory in getting
support for a tougher stance on china
as well as a plan to invest perhaps
trillions in developing countries to
create an economic
counterweight to beijing's belt and road
initiative with higher standards for
human rights and labor
the g7 explicitly agreed to call out
human rights abuses
in xinjiang and hong kong explicitly
two to coordinate a common strategy to
deal with china
non-market policies that undermine
competition they've agreed and that's
underway now how to do that
three to take serious actions against
forced labor
in solar agriculture and the garment
industries because that's where it's
happening
and they've agreed we will do that the
final communique also emphasizes the
need for a thorough investigation into
the origins of covid19
including in china that's aimed at
preventing another pandemic
while german chancellor angela merkel
welcomed the pledge to donate more
vaccines now
to end this one here van buren
we agreed this pandemic can only be
defeated globally
the way out of the pandemic is vaccines
we must ensure access to vaccines for
all
but warming ties among global leaders
didn't produce much action against
global warming the g7 renuda pledged to
raise a hundred billion dollars per year
to help poor countries deal with climate
change that was due to be fulfilled
already last year never before in the
history of the g7
has been such a big failure in contrast
to what needs to be done
more protesters await biden and his
european counterparts in brussels
as they meet monday for a summit at nato
for more we're joined now by our chief
international editor richard
walker richard host boris johnson put a
very positive spin
on that summit was it really as
successful as he makes it out to be
yeah well terry it is natural for the
summit host to put a positive spin on
things especially if you're boris
johnson of course that's
that's his style but i think much more
important here than the hosts
are the americans of course because this
was joe biden's uh debut or kind of
re-entry to the world state since
becoming president earlier this year and
his team is going to be pretty happy i
think
uh uh going back home uh after this or
rather going on to brussels for the nato
summit i mean their goal broadly has
been
projecting unity and projecting
competence and i think on both fronts
they're going to be fairly happy on
unity it's true
northern ireland has been a a bug bear
between the
eu and the uk and that sort of squabble
is not resolved yet
that is a bit of a fly in the ointment
but the broader picture of the west kind
of rallying together and saying that we
want to take on the big challenges these
kind of competence issues like we can
deal with a pandemic we can deal with
economic recovery
we can deal with climate change for all
of the criticism that there are on these
individual points still the g7 is saying
we are here we are able to do these
things
and i think the biden team will be quite
happy with that
now the g7 singled out china for
criticism richard scolding it over human
rights violations and
unfair trade practices how's this going
to affect
relations with china
well the chinese are definitely not
going to be happy with this their
embassy in london in fact put out a
statement before their g7 communique
came out sort of saying you know
these this is not the club that rules
the world anymore
but this was really a key area where
biden sought that unity and he seems to
have got
a decent amount of it i mean biden is
framing this era as a kind of battle of
the systems between democracies and
autocracies and many europeans are very
uncomfortable about that particularly
here in germany where
the economy is highly dependent on china
they're very concerned about
about you know getting into too
confrontational a situation with china
and yet despite that they communicate
this
statement at the end of the summit
singled out china over four distinct
areas and
implicitly singled out china in many
other areas too
i think again on this the biden team are
going to be quite happy
richard thank you so much our chief
international editor richard walker
you